well there's a young man from las vegas
who is scheduled to be on jeopardy
tonight
and he was the captain of his high
school's varsity quiz
team on vegas pbs back in 2014.
it's varsity quiz we also have the
captain of liberty
he's a senior braden smith hey braden
hey um
i know a lot of people probably know
this but briefly describe what boys
state
is well it's this sort of mock
government thing that goes on every year
well braden was the winner of that
year's varsity quiz harvey dondero
scholarship to help fund his college
education
his mom tells me he graduated in may
from unlv with a degree in economics
and that he's looking to go to law
school now so good luck to braden smith
on jeopardy tonight at seven
right here on channel eight so cool that
a kid who was on a local high school
quiz show that i have the honor of
hosting
he's now made it to jeopardy alex woo
hoo
go brayden what a smart man i love
seeing you host those things too nate
that is so fun yeah
well we're trying to figure out how to
do it this year we just did the spelling
bee
on a google meet meeting and i know that
there have been some
varsity quiz matches on zoom or google
meet so we're trying to figure out how
to do it this year
yeah nate it's like the farm team for
game shows
you cut your teeth on vegas pbs you work
your way up maybe up to jeopardy and
then next after that there's you know
amazing race or something or the mask
singer